[Music]
well thanks everybody for coming here
today and for all the people who are
listening to the live stream the impetus
for this event here in Washington DC is
Ben Bernanke chairman the Federal
Reserve has just finished a four-part
lectures here series at George
Washington University how many people
who are here were participate in that
lecture series by show of hands
all right few of you know apparently it
was sponsored by the Economics
Department but they had that wrong see
they really should have sponsored his
lecture through the drama department
because everything you said was just
pure fantasy I think it was Ben
Bernanke's distorted view of what
actually happened so what I wanted to do
is set the record straight and actually
speak about the facts not only the facts
of the financial crisis and the feds key
role in causing it and inflating the
housing bubble but go back to the
beginning the Federal Reserve's
formation because Ben Bernanke basically
presented a completely revisionist view
of history not only recent history that
we just lived through but the history of
the formation of the Fed and most
importantly the Great Depression and an
interesting thing is Ben Bernanke
fancies himself as a student of the
Great Depression
but based on his presentation if he was
my student he would have gotten an F he
doesn't understand anything about the
Great Depression and he doesn't say
understand anything about the the
financial crisis or the depression that
either were in or we're heading for so
what I want to do is I want to start off
where Bernanke
I got a bunch of his slides not all of
his slides because there's too many we
can't get them all into an hour so we
picked up some of the slides and I'm
going to put those slides up here and
then just comment on them and when I'm
finished with all the slides I'll talk
about whatever I couldn't address with
the slides until you know the hour was
up so he started off by talking about
why do we have the central bank and why
was it creative course was created in
1913 and according to Ben Bernanke we
needed this Federal Reserve because
before the Federal
we didn't have any stability in a
banking system we had constant booms and
busts and he talked about he talked
about some of the more famous panics
that happened in the 19th century and he
said that we needed the Federal Reserve
in order to to do this in fact he talked
about the banks as inherently being
unstable in that they could be subjected
to a run because banks would take in
deposits and they would loan them out
and what might happen to a bank if
depositors wanted their money but they
couldn't get it because the banks had
loaned it out and so the whole idea is
they'd have this lender of last resort
that would be there and that would make
sure we didn't have bank runs and we
didn't have all these panics and so
that's why we had the Federal Reserve
now what Ben Bernanke really didn't
discuss is that the record of stability
was better before we had the Fed than
with in fact the biggest busts and booms
happened with the Federal Reserve not
without the Federal Reserve and we
weren't having constant runs on banks
before we had a Federal Reserve yes we
did have bank failures in the Great
Depression I don't to get into the feds
role and the government's role in
creating that you know in a minute but
even with all of the bank failures in
the Great Depression only about 2% of
deposits were actually lost so is very
small amount of deposits I mean we lose
more than 2% of the value of our
deposits every year now to inflation so
this is just a myth and in fact banks
are just like any other business
absent government intervention banks are
going to compete with one another based
on reputation banks don't want to run
they don't want their customers worried
about their deposits so there is
competition banks are going to hold
adequate reserves so that their
customers are not concerned and so that
they can meet whatever demands might be
placed upon them this is what happens in
a free market the banker decides how
many how much reserves am I going to
keep what am I going to loan out what
happens is when the government comes in
with the FDIC and they have the Federal
Reserve as this lender of last resort
now the banks have no market-based
incentives to be prudent
it doesn't matter they'll loan out as
much as the government will let them
because now there's no concern because
their customers know that the government
stands behind the deposits so it's
instability by interjecting that moral
hazard by bringing a Fed in there and
the FDIC you actually destabilize the
banking system because you removed all
of the market safeguards that would have
protected the banks the banks would have
kept adequate reserves because they have
they knew their depositors would want
that but now with the defending the FDIC
we have a lot more lending and a lot
more risk taking on the part of the
banks because the government has come in
and created this moral hazard and
created a situation where bank customers
no longer care about the solvency of the
banks that is a big problem so in fact
the Fed created the exact opposite of
what Bernanke said as he went into the
creation the Federal Reserve he talked
about the the limitations of the gold
standard because of course prior to the
Federal Reserve we were on a gold
standard although when we created the
Federal Reserve we didn't leave the gold
standard we were still on the gold
standard in fact Federal Reserve notes
how to be backed 40 percent by gold and
the notes were still redeemable you know
so we were on a gold standard exist that
we had the Federal Reserve issuing notes
backed by gold as opposed to maybe
independent banks that were issuing
their own notes that were backed by gold
so we didn't let leave the gold standard
you can say we modified it a bit but Ben
Bernanke was very critical the gold
standard and his main criticism was that
it took away the flexibility of
government and bankers to try to
micromanage the economy from Washington
well that's not what's wrong with it
that's it this greatest virtue is that
it stops people from bent like Ben
Bernanke or Alan Greenspan from
destroying the economy the whole idea
that central bankers know more than the
free market that they know what interest
rates should be you know we have
interest rates in America that are not
set by the free market in a gold
standard interest rates are set in the
market in the system we have now we have
central planners like in the old
Politburo in the Soviet Union that sit
around and try to guess what the
appropriate rate of interest should be
and then they set that rate and that's
what we do now
where does ben bernanke have interest
rates Eddie's price fixed them at
practically zero the biggest problem
with the US economy is that interest
rates are too low the Fed is distorting
the economy with these low interest
rates none of this would happen under a
gold standard we get the right interest
rate because the price would be set in
the free market and you know that
interest rates are too low because
nobody is saving we have all this debt
and we have and we have no savings
because rates are too low the market
would bring rates up higher rates would
encourage savings would discourage
borrowing and consumption and we go back
into equilibrium but the Federal Reserve
is there if the gold standard was there
this couldn't happen
another problem is with the deficits
gold limits the ability of the federal
of the government to spend beyond its
means but with a Federal Reserve that's
going to buy up government bonds and
monetize the debt now they call it QE
but this allows the government to be
fiscally irresponsible Gold would rein
in excess government spending but with
the Federal Reserve there is nothing to
rein in excess government spending and
that's why the government is able to
spend so much so that it was the
strength of gold that Bernanke is
actually criticism because Bernanke
wants that power he actually believes
and based on the evidence I don't know
how he can believe this because the
guy's never got anything right in his
life but somehow he thinks he's so much
smarter and so he thinks were better off
letting him make all these decisions
than letting these decisions be made in
the free market with real money which
was gold and of course we were in the
gold standard the founding fathers put
us on the gold standard and we really
stayed on the gold standard in one form
or another all the way until 1971 so to
say that we went off the gold standard
when we brought the Federal Reserve in
is not the case but we certainly changed
it a bit
so here's where now he gets into the
great depression okay and this is where
Ben Bernanke really really you know goes
off the deep end in his historical
account of the Great Depression but
before I even talk about the Great
Depression I want to talk about the
depression that Bernanke didn't even
mention because it doesn't fit into his
narrative and that's the one we had in
nineteen twenty now while people don't
know about this depression because it
was over very quickly but it began for
the same reasons that the Depression of
1929 began
right we had a stock market that
collapsed in 1920 stock market dropped
by about 40 percent one year the Dow the
GDP collapsed by 17 percent in a single
year 17 percent and unemployment
skyrocketed from 4 percent to 12 percent
in one year and why did this happen well
world war 1 started in 1917
the Federal Reserve was created in 1913
when we entered the war court know the
war didn't start in 1917 that's when we
entered it when we entered the war the
government wanted to help pay for the
war by borrowing money and it wanted to
borrow from the Fed but there was a
problem you see the original Federal
Reserve Act it prohibited the Federal
Reserve from owning any US Treasuries
and that made a lot of sense because
they didn't want the Federal Reserve to
own Treasuries because they didn't want
it to be an engine of inflation they
didn't want the Federal Reserve to lend
money to the government or buy
government bonds so it wasn't allowed to
do it so they went in and they amended
the Act to allow for it which shows you
how dangerous this was it was love
classic you get the camels nose under
the tent so they put it in with that
restriction and then late and then a few
years later they took it away and it's
also entering an interesting bit of
trivia when they did that that's when
they first came up with the idea of the
debt ceiling now we're always talking
about the debt ceiling now well that's
when it started when the Federal Reserve
was given the power to buy bonds for
Treasury bonds people were concerned
well this could be very dangerous this
could really lead to a lot of debt so
they decided to put a limit on how much
debt the Treasury could have now that
they made it easier for the Treasury to
borrow of course the problem was you
could raise the ceiling which they've
done every time they've gone near it but
so we amended the Federal Reserve Act
and the Federal Reserve bought a bunch
of Treasuries and how do they do that
they printed money so the monetary
spigots were opened up at that time and
it destabilized you know to cheat money
when the war ended they turn the spigots
off and then we had a bus we had a we
had a little boom created by the Fed and
then we had a bust and in fact before I
even talk about this I want to just
spend a few minutes on the business
cycle because that's another thing that
Ben Bernanke doesn't understand
the the recessions are not the problems
the booms are the problems the
recessions are the cures see the
government creates a phony boom by
keeping interest rates too low by
creating too much money and you get a
misallocation of resources land labor
and capital and and what happens is you
have now investments you make mistakes
and then eventually the bubble bursts
and you have a recession and that is the
time where the market is trying to fix
the mistakes that were made during the
boom the problem is when the Fed looks
at the recession it doesn't see that as
the cure it sees that as the problem and
it tries to cure it with more of the
same monetary stimulus that created the
prior boom and so it interferes with the
markets attempt to restructure the
economy and it makes bigger problems and
we're going to get into that later in
this discussion but so to go back to the
19th 1920 so the Fed turns off the
monetary spigot and we get this huge
class stock market crashes GDP crashes
unemployment skyrockets and the
President Warren Harding okay what are
we gonna do well he had a Secretary of
Commerce Herbert Hoover Herbert Hoover
was like oh no this is terrible
we need massive government stimulus and
he probably didn't use the word stimulus
but that's you know what he would have
said today he said the government needs
to intervene we need to stimulate the
economy you know we need we the
government has to help we can't go
through this this is such a bad downturn
we can't let the market do this we need
decisive intervention by the government
and Harding was oh no no we don't need
that we need the opposite and what did
Harding do in response to this downturn
he slashed government spending despite
this huge declines seventeen percent
drop in GDP twelve percent unemployment
he cut government spending right the
exact opposite of what the Keynesian say
you have to do and what did the Fed do
absolutely nothing the Fed didn't cut
rates it didn't ease and what happened
as a result of doing nothing well within
a year the unemployment rate was cut in
half
in two years it was below 3% it went
from four 12% to under 3% in two years
the stock market fully recovered
everything it lost
problem solved the governor didn't do a
thing now let's talk about the
depression that Ben Bernanke wants to
talk about and of course it's also
important to note that this happened
with the Fed this huge decline happened
with the Fed not before but now let's
talk about the next depression the crash
1929 but also I got to talk about one
thing that Ben Bernanke didn't talk
about he talked about the crash in a
stock market and the Great Depression
but he didn't talk about why why we had
a crash well the reason we had a crash
is because we had a phony boom that
preceded that crash and why did we have
that well that was because of the
Federal Reserve the Federal Reserve had
interest rates too low for the second
half of the 1920s and they printed too
much money now why did they do that well
first there was a little bit of an
economic downturn in 1927 that the Fed
wanted to you know lean against was
stimulus so they tried to fight a
contraction with cheap money that's a
very familiar story now but also you had
a problem in in the UK where there was a
run on the British Pound the British
were losing gold they were on a gold
standard too and they had their interest
rates too low as a result they were
losing gold to the United States people
were getting out of the pound of the
dollar and so in order to make the
dollar less attractive relative to the
pound they flooded the market with with
liquidity to try to drive down US rates
to try to stop the drain of gold out of
Britain and all of that liquidity went
right into the stock market you look at
a chart look at stocks and I actually
have a fact I have this chart here
somewhere but you know I don't want to
fast forward it because I want to talk
about something first I'll show you that
chart when I get to it but the stock
market just took off right now in late
1928 Benjamin strong who was the head of
the New York branch of the Federal
Reserve died and he was the big
proponent of this cheap money
he was buddies with a guy over there in
the UK and so when he died the Federal
Reserve recognized that there's a huge
bubble they made a big mistake and they
started they raised rates which is what
they should have done and then the stock
market bubble burst in 1929 just like it
did just like this and a stock dropped
sharply you know and we started a
depression just
like the depression in 1920 except this
time it's different this time
the the Secretary of Commerce Herbert
Hoover is now the president and now he
can do all the things that he wanted to
do in 1920 but that Warren Harding was
smart enough not to let him do here is a
quote a famous quote from Andrew Mellon
who was the Secretary of Treasury under
Hoover liquidate labor liquidate stocks
liquidate the farmers liquidate real
estate write liquidation is theory right
now Byrne Ben Bernanke is presenting
this as if that is what we did but this
is exactly what we did not do this is
what Andrew Mellon wanted Hoover to do
and Hoover said no and Hoover against
that advice was the most interventionist
president in history I mean maybe he
would be the modern equivalent right now
of George Bush and the way he originally
reacted to the financial crisis and in
fact when Hoover ran for re-election at
his nomination for a second term and you
can look at his speech he bragged about
the fact that he refused to listen to to
mail it and that he did all this
unprecedented stimulus and it was all
that stimulus that got in the way
of the recovery had Hoover actually done
what Ben Bernanke accused him of doing
there wouldn't have been a Great
Depression and there would have been
nothing for him to study or apparently
not study and it would have been over
and the interesting thing is and this is
where the parallels really get big
Roosevelt ran against Hoover because he
was too spending too much
he said elect mean I'll balance the
budget he promised change he said this
guy Hoover is a reckless spender he's
running up the deficits elect me and I'm
going to cut spending and balance the
budget that is how Roosevelt ran right
like Obama change but when he won what
did he do he took Hoover's policies and
called it the New Deal and expanded him
he took the exact same policies and made
it bigger right which is what Obama has
done he's taken he's taken Bush's
policies and just expanded them
and so the Great Depression was not
caused for the reasons that Ben Bernanke
in fact Ben Bernanke his only criticism
of the Fed is that they tightened too
much right they tightened too much in
1931 or 1932 he doesn't criticize him at
all for being too loose during the 1920s
he says they were too tight in the 1930s
and even his predecessor even Alan
Greenspan admits that the Federal
Reserve caused the stock market bubble
in the 1920s he says that he wrote that
that it was the feds easy-money policy
that inflated that bubble and the
mistake was not raising interest rates
it was that they lowered them and
according to Ben Bernanke if the Fed
adjust kept printing and printing and
printing that things would have been
better no they wouldn't have they would
have been worse that Ben Bernanke was in
charge who knows we might still be in
that depression but his policy
prescription is the exact opposite and
he didn't learn any lessons at all from
the Great Depression that's why he's
repeating all these mistakes ok then he
went over the period of the 1960s and
a-19 said we're here he gets it right a
little bit where he talks about monetary
policy being too easy and the inflation
rate was about 13% but look we're even
easier now than we were the 1960s the
question is why is inflation not 13% now
like it was then when the answer is well
it probably is it's just that we're
measuring it differently you know I had
this conversation with Paul Volcker just
got a couple weeks ago kind of you know
behind the scenes because I said to Paul
Volcker I said you know how do you feel
having overreacted the way you did to in
phony to the inflation that didn't exist
back in the 1970s and I said what are
you talking
I said well if we have the CPI today
back then if we had the same methodology
for calculating it you would have seen
that there was no inflation in the 1970s
either and therefore there was no need
for you to raise interest rate so high
but he was right in that yes the Fed was
too easy during the 1960s and during the
1960s that's soda seed for the 1970s but
the problem is we printed all this money
so we didn't get the big stock market
crash
during the 1970s that we had during the
1930s in terms of dollars but we did in
terms of gold if you look at the decline
in real terms the stock market was worth
about 20 ounces of gold in 1929 it
bottomed out at about 1 ounce of gold in
1932 in 1966 the Dow was worth over 20
ounces of gold and by 1980 it was one
ounce of gold so we have the same
collapse it just happened in gold terms
not paper terms because the Federal
Reserve printed so much money which is
the reason that prices rose so much
during that period of time that's why
oil prices went from $3 a barrel to $30
a barrel and that's why oil prices are
rising today it's not because of Iran
it's because of the Fed it's because the
Fed is printing up all this money the
price of oil is going up in dollars it's
not going down in terms of real money
you can still buy a gallon of gasoline
for less money that it costs in the
1950s in 1950s you can buy a gallon of
gasoline for a quarter today you can buy
a gallon of gasoline it costs less than
a quarter but you have to have the same
quarter yep have a quarter made of
silver so he was a little bit more
accurate about this period of time
why was - why was my okay okay here's
the here's the Sharpe the chart I wanted
to show you of the stock market here you
can see that drop right down like that's
the depression 1921 you can see that 40%
drop in the stock market and then it
immediately recovered and if you look at
the big ballistic move in the stock
market in the late like 1927 on that's
all that money all that cheap money that
the Fed put into the system
send stocks up into the stratosphere and
then when they took the cheap money away
the market collapsed and that and that
started the Great Depression but what
really made it great was Hoover and
Roosevelt interfering and and not
allowing the market to correct all the
MAL investments that were made during
during that period of time right now to
go from the sublime to the ridiculous
it's Ben Bernanke's discussion of the
housing bubble all right now
ben bernanke and i get is talking about
the housing bubble and according to Ben
Bernanke and you can see you know the
Chara housing prices where they go
ballistic and it's maybe it's in that
the later slide but I'm just going to
talk about our service slices Ben
Bernanke says that there are some people
out there who believe for some crazy
reason that the feds low interest rate
had something to do with the housing
bubble right now of course I don't think
the Fed had something to do with the
housing bubble I mean if the housing
bubble was a baby the Fed fathered it
and and and raised it and nurtured it I
mean it defend created it right it
wasn't that they had something to do
with it they had everything to do with
it now Ben Bernanke claims that all the
evidence shows that the feds policies
had nothing to do with the housing
bubble well I don't know what evidence
he's looking at right but all the
evidence shows the opposite the Court of
Federal Reserve the Fed had nothing to
do with the housing bubble
now before I even discuss point by point
his ridiculous arguments think about the
credit the feds credibility on the
housing bubble in 2004 all right this is
pretty serious into the bubble in 2004
the Federal Reserve Bank of New York put
out an intricate detailed study because
they wanted to study whether or not
there was a housing bubble bubble so
they put out a huge study and they came
back and the conclusion of the Federal
Reserve was there is no evidence of a
housing bubble now when this thing came
out I was shocked I'm like what is no
evidence what are they blind and I was
you could read all the stuff I was
writing back in 2004 I published it I
sent it out to hundreds of reporters I
gave them all the evidence that the Fed
was ignoring of a housing bubble and to
me at the time there was so much
evidence of a bubble it was so obvious
that I thought how could they possibly
miss it and I started to think you know
maybe this is just pure like propaganda
I mean the Fed is so concerned about the
housing bubble and they know people are
figuring it out that they're trying to
you know they're trying to lie to us so
that we don't know about it because the
Fed wanted to maintain the cheap money
in 2004 and but if they knew there was a
housing bubble and it was being fueled
by the cheap it money they would
have to raise interest rates they didn't
want to raise interest rates so they had
to pretend there was no housing bubble
that needed to burst
so they trumped up this phony study but
those are the only two explanations
either the study is phony
and it was deliberately designed to be
used as PR even though the Fed knew
there was a housing bubble or the Fed is
completely incompetent and they couldn't
figure it out even though it was the
biggest bubble in our history but not
only the Fed itself couldn't figure it
out Ben Bernanke you can go and look
even on YouTube there's you know the
YouTube video peter schiff was right
which has some of my TV appearances from
you know 2006 and seven well there's
another video not as many people have
seen it it's called Ben Bernanke was
wrong and I didn't do this one but it
has ben bernanke going on CNBC a few
times in 2005 and 2006
specifically saying there's no housing
bubble it doesn't exist right that the
housing prices are supported by solid
fundamentals and then Ben Bernanke went
on to say even if housing prices go down
it's not going to have any impact on
employment this is what this guy said so
let's get this straight a guy who not
only couldn't see the housing bubble
even at its peak in fact even after it
burst
he still denied it existed this is the
guy that's telling us that the Fed
didn't cause it well if he didn't see it
how does he know maybe he caused it by
accident but PETA obviously doesn't
understand it unless he's lying about
and of course if he's lying then he has
no credibility anyway because he's just
saying it but he asks if he actually
believes what he's saying well how can
we trust them he obviously has a lousy
track record in fact the guy knows so
little about the housing market that
even after the the subprime crisis hit
what did Ben Bernanke say don't worry
about it it's contained it's contained a
subprime he still didn't get it even
that late in the game with all the
evidence he was completely clueless I
mean either that or it was he was just
giving out disinformation
but either he has no credibility or he
has no competence you got to figure out
which one it is but those are the only
choices so given the fact that Ben
Bernanke didn't see that crisis coming
he
got no credibility as to offering an
explanation contrast that to me I wrote
dozens of articles from 2004 to 2007
detailing in specifics exactly why there
was a housing bubble all the evidence of
the bubble why was being created and
what was going to happen after it burst
and the reason that I knew this and
again I'm not the only one there other
people that knew it and the reason I
knew it is because I understood how his
policy was creating it the housing
bubble was a function of the cheap money
that was fueling it now yes did it
didn't it wasn't only the Fed it was the
Fed and Freddie and Fannie and the FHA
and you know it was the government
guaranteed mortgages combined with the
cheap money that did it right it wasn't
just the Fed but the Fed was the
principal actor and then government
through their sponsored enterprises was
secondary but that's it but it's
coincidence interesting too that not
only does Ben Bernanke completely
dissolve absolve the Fed from any
responsibility
he also completely absolved Fannie and
Freddie according to Ben Bernanke it's
all Wall Street's fault that another
dude it's like yeah had nothing with him
right Wall Street got drunk right
according to George Bush yet the
bartender doesn't want to take any
responsibility for littering everybody
up and then he lets Freddie and Fannie
off the hook to here's his evidence that
suggests otherwise
okay first he says that the United
Kingdom had a housing boom during the
20s despite tighter monetary policy the
United States yes it was not as loose as
the United States but it wasn't tight
they had cheap money all around the
world that's what Ben Bernanke doesn't
get we had the reserve currency
we had interest rates too low so the
whole world followed in our bad example
that's why real estate prices were
rising globally because money was cheap
everywhere it wasn't just cheap in
America it was cheap everywhere but it
was cheaper here and the difference is
the UK didn't have Fannie and Freddie in
the FHA and we did and so there was a
huge difference here size of the bubble
change the mortgage rate during the boom
years seem to be far too small to
account for what
not I mean the change in the mortgage
rate was enormous especially when you
consider the fact that people were able
to get adjustable rate mortgages see Ben
Bernanke doesn't seem to understand that
would fueled the housing bubble wasn't a
30-year fixed-rate mortgage
it was the teaser rate on a two and
twenty eight arm and where did that
teaser rate come from it was a gift from
the Fed the Fed lowered interest rates
down to one percent and that brought
those teaser rates down and here is the
real thing that Ben Bernanke doesn't
understand about Freddie and Fannie
Freddie and Fannie were the leaders in
the charge to lower lending standards
what Freddie and Fannie decided to do
for their conforming loans because they
have to guarantee the loans and there is
a certain income standard that Fannie
and Freddie said if you want to borrow a
certain amount of money your income has
to be a certain percentage of your
mortgage payments right now what Fannie
and Freddie decided to do was fixed that
qualification to the teaser rate not to
the reset rates so let's say somebody
applied for a mortgage where for the
first two years the interest rate was 3%
and then it jumped up to 7% and maybe
that meant that for the first two years
the monthly payments were $500 and then
they jumped up to $1500 right the Fed
was going to Fannie and Freddie we're
going to guarantee that mortgage based
on the borrower's ability to pay the 500
a month they didn't care if the 1500 a
month exceeded his monthly income they
didn't care they simply were
guaranteeing mortgages based on the
teaser rate that's why these things
became so so popular because you could
borrow well beyond your ability to pay
back the loan because the government was
going to guarantee the mortgage anyway
so the government got the housing bubble
going with cheap money and low lending
standards from Fannie and Freddie only
at the end did the private sector come
in with the securitization market of
subprime but only because Fannie and
Freddie were the biggest customers for
Wall Street
Fannie and Freddie bought half the paper
that Wall Street securitized without
that big buyer they wouldn't have
secured ties at all and without Fannie
and Freddie buying it other people would
have been too scared to buy it but since
Fannie and Freddie put their good
government seal of approval on Hollis
other other people were buying but to
say that Wall Street created the problem
and it wasn't Freddie and Fannie is it's
ridiculous Freddie and Fannie was right
at the center of this thing here here is
where he really goes off the deep end -
he says timing housing prices began to
pick up in the late 1990s before the
monetary policy began easing and so
therefore it couldn't have been the
result of their policy plus it kept
going up after they tightened in 2004
all right now here here's what happened
if you look at a chart of housing prices
and in the stock market they really
started going up you know in the second
half of the 1990s and and real estate
prices really began their ascent in 1996
97 ish that's when the housing bubble
started but it's not as if the cheap
money policies started in 2001 the cheap
money is what fueled the entire stock
market bubble that burst in 2000 the Fed
under alan greenspan kept interest rates
too low for the entire decade
particularly the second half of the
1990s every time there was a problem in
the world long-term capital management
you know russian debt contagion orange
county went bankrupt you know y2k
concerned whatever happened Greenspan
was there in fact he was so friendly to
Wall Street they had Wall Street came up
an it with a name
the Greenspan put nothing can go wrong
because Greenspan's got your back so we
had all this cheap money a lot of it
went into the stock market but some of
it went into the real estate market so
the real estate bubble began in the
1990s as a consequence of the feds cheap
money but it was obscured by the larger
bubble in the stock market and in fact
the stock market bubble was helping to
fuel the real estate bubble because
people were taking their stock market
gains and using it to put a down payment
on a house in fact a lot of people who
were buying houses were cashing out
options because they worked at a dot-com
company and they became overnight
millionaires and they went and bought a
house because I remember I got married
in in 2000 and I was ok the stock market
is going to crash I number my wife at
the time wanted me to buy a house I said
I'm not going to buy a house because the
stock market is going to crash and then
real estate prices are going to come
down
- we'll wait for the dip and then we'll
buy and of course I was right the stock
market crashed
but the real estate market did it so
when the real estate bubble burst and
the Fed immediately did the wrong thing
again by slashing interest rates down to
1% they didn't really reflect the
bursted Nasdaq bubble but they
perpetuated and accelerate the smaller
bubble in real estate and they really
lit a fire under the real estate bubble
so real estate prices began to rise even
more after the feds last rates but that
doesn't mean that the Fed wasn't
responsible for getting it going prior
to that by having rates too cheap when
they when they produced a housing bubble
now had the Fed not stimulated the
economy in 2001 with cutting interest
rates to 1% the real estate bubble would
have been would have been sniffed in its
infancy real-estate prices would have
come down right then they would have
reversed those gains from 2006 from 1996
to 2000 we would have had a deeper
recession but we never would've had a
housing bubble we never would have had
the financial crisis of 2008 that was
the the withdrawal from the Fed stimulus
in OH 1 now when when Ben Bernanke says
we started raising interest rates in
2004 but real estate prices kept rising
well they rose for two more years the
peak was in 2006 the problem wasn't that
they raised them is that they raised
them too slowly they raised them at one
quarter point increments that wasn't
enough in fact I wrote an op-ed it was
either in 2004 or 2005 but he goes oh 4
in the Orange County Register it was
called a tender trap of adjustment
mortgages and in that op-ed I said the
Fed is raising rates too slowly it needs
to raise them aggressively the longer
they wait for aggressive rate hikes I
said the more people who are going to be
lured into this tender trap of
adjustable rate mortgages these tiny
increases kept the party going and in
fact as rates were going up it
accelerated the demand for houses
because people wanted to buy before the
race went even higher so everybody was
rushing in to buy and lock in these
teaser rates so they can buy these
houses had the Fed been aggressive had
we not went in a measured pace Ed Alan
Greenspan not raised rates 1/4 of a
point every
couple of months had he just taken them
up two or three hundred basis points
moved him up he would have nipped it in
the bud but you know it's one or two
things is is there's one or two
possibilities alan greenspan at the time
knew that the phony recovery was built
on this housing bubble and he didn't
want to prick it and so he was very
careful to raise rates very slowly so as
not to prick the housing bubble to keep
it going for political reasons or he was
totally oblivious it had no idea that
there was a housing bubble but obviously
if the Fed had known there was a housing
bubble and they were acting responsibly
they wouldn't have raised rates by a
quarter of a point they would have been
far more aggressive but the fact of the
matter is they were too slow and they
perpetuated this bubble think about all
the adjustment rate mortgages that were
taken out between 2004 and 2006 all the
worst paper was originated at that
period of time all the stuff that Willy
went bankrupt and it was because even
though rates were 1% so he went to one
and a quarter one and a half one in
three quarters to those rates were still
ridiculously low and so the Fed did this
and the reason that I was able to figure
this out so easily and again the person
who introduced me mentioned my my speech
in front of the Mortgage Bankers
Association just go to youtube and type
in Peter Schiff mortgage bankers and and
listen to what I was saying in 2006 I
said the same stuff in 2005 and then
listen to what Ben Bernanke was saying
and determine who has credibility I mean
how did I know all this stuff was going
to happen because I understood how the
feds policy was distorting the market
how was creating a bubble in their
housing market I understood how the
entire economy was dependent on that
bubble on the spending of phony real
estate wealth I knew how leverage the
banking structure center section sector
was - this phony collateral I knew that
when the bubble burst the banks would
fail Fannie and Freddie would go
bankrupt and I also knew more
importantly that the government would
once again do the wrong thing and the
Fed would do the wrong thing repeat
their mistakes of 2001 which is exactly
what they did this is a slide that
wasn't in his presentation but anyway so
what did did Ben Bernanke learn from the
mistakes of Alan Greenspan no he
repeated them by lowering
rates to 1% we inflated a week we really
inflated this huge real-estate bubble
that the Fed began to inflate when rates
were too low in the 1990s the defense
from his mistakes no we're our interest
rates today they're at zero they're even
lower than they were at any point in the
greenspan term and he's kept them there
for years and he's promising to keep
them there for years more so you got to
ask yourself if the Fed did so much
damage with a monetary policy that's not
nearly as reckless as the one that we
have now imagine what is in store for
the US economy when we get to hang over
when this stimulus wears off and think
about the Keynesian stimulus that we got
from from Bush with those budget
deficits the Obama deficits dwarfed the
bush deficits so unfortunately just like
the the housing bubbles the bursting of
the housing bubble had more dire
consequences than the bursting of the
stock market bubble the bursting of this
next bubble which I have described as a
government bubble you can see that in
the bond market in the foreign exchange
market when this bubble bursts it's
going to be much more disastrous see
people think the US economy is
recovering well they made the same
mistake during the housing bubble the
Fed confused the housing bubble with a
legitimate recovery it's making the same
mistake now we're not recovering we're
just spending ourselves into a deeper
hole we're spending more borrowed money
and we're counting the spending as a
growing economy all that's growing is
our debt and remember when we had this
housing bubble Ben Bernanke said it
didn't exist
well now it's saying the same thing
about inflation the Fed is saying
there's no inflation there's no evidence
inflation even though you can see the
inflation everywhere well there is
inflation just like there was a housing
bubble at the Fed didn't see there's
inflation that the Fed doesn't see and
eventually interest rates are going to
have to rise dramatically and when they
do just like when they rose on the
mortgage markets and all the subprime
buyers couldn't afford to pay their
mortgages when the rates reset the US
government can't afford to pay interest
on the national debt that's now enormous
when the rates go up
homeowners are going to be in trouble
when they're adjustable rate mortgages
go up the banks are going to collapse
again bigger than the last time when
rates go up in their
lateral evaporates and you know their
income turns into losses so
unfortunately rather than saving us like
Ben Bernanke's version of history the
Fed created the problem they made it
worse
and now we're in for a much greater
catastrophe because of the Federal
Reserve and you know I got this chart up
here Ben Bernanke tried to talk about
you know what a great job the Federal
Reserve has done how much better off we
are with a Federal Reserve than without
the Federal Reserve well here's this
chart and you can see 1913 right there
this is prices this is what happened to
prices so without the Federal Reserve
prices were falling this is an index a
CPI index where 100 and this is created
by the Fed 1967 is a hundred so you can
see here at about 1800 you know you're
around close to 40 and by 1900 you're
closer to 20 right so consumer prices
were lower in 1900 than they were in
1800 that sound money that means money
gained value over that 100 year period
of time money gained purchasing power
without the Federal Reserve because what
did we have we had deflation for over a
hundred years now according to the Fed
deflation is the worst thing that you
can possibly have
well the 19th century by anyway you want
to measure it was a more prosperous
century than the 20th we had much more
economic growth living standards rose at
a higher pace during that century then
during the 20th century and it happened
with a gold standard without a central
bank and it happened with with deflation
now get the government thinks deflation
is is is is is some kind of you know
pestilence that they've got to protect
us from it's not it is the reward of
free capitalism it is the way the
average man benefits from capitalism is
that the cost of living goes down and
his standard of living goes up so the
government makes these phony arguments
they say well if we have the flay ssin
nobody will buy anything because prices
will be falling and so the whole economy
will seize up because people will be
waiting for lower prices and so nobody
will buy well that's complete hogwash
I mean people buy cell phones all the
time people buy laptop computers people
buy plasma TVs the price keeps going
down and they keep buying in fact the
reason that people
are buying is precisely because the
prices are going down it's falling
prices that created them in the first
cellphone that came out probably was
about $2,000
very few people bought it because it was
so expensive and then if you wanted to
make a call it was really expensive what
created demand for cell phones the price
came down and as the price came down
people bought it and the companies made
more money see the other argument
against deflation is that well the
businesses will fail because they won't
be able to make any profits with falling
prices they make more profits with
falling prices because their costs are
falling and with lower prices you get
more volume there the cellphone
companies are making a lot more money
selling millions of cellphones at 50 or
100 bucks apiece than they were when
they sold a few thousand a couple of
thousand dollars apiece it's happened
with everything you know any guy that
owns a retail outlet knows that if you
want to motivate your customers you have
a sale you buy you know so this is this
is this is all cover the Fed wants to
create inflation so in order to create
an environment where inflation is
considered good the government has to
first say that the opposite of inflation
deflation is bad see and effect and then
Bernanke claims that the goal of the Fed
is price stability well that was their
goal they failed miserably see look at
the record before the Fed and look at
prices going through the roof now this
chart only goes up to 1975 I got another
one but look at how prices are
skyrocketing once we get the Federal
Reserve and also one a point out people
want to say that you couldn't make any
money Oh businesses can't make money
under deflation right the greatest
American fortunes were accumulated in
the nineteenth century not the 20th
century if you want to look at the 30
richest Americans of all time self-made
adjusted for inflation only three out of
33 were born after the Civil War the
other 27 were born before the Civil War
and of those three there's only one who
was born after the Second World War
so people were able to make a tremendous
amount of money in a deflationary
involvement environment and in making
that money they created the American
middle class people were emigrating from
all around
the world to participate in this
economic miracle of freedom of sound
money and the government was tiny you
know in 1900 the government at all
levels state federal and local spent 3%
of the GNP that's it 3% today that
number is better than 40% the government
is more than ten times bigger as a
percentage of the economy but that's why
the economy is not as productive as it
was that's why we can't create wealth
the way we did back then and how did the
government get so big what enabled the
government to grow that big I would
argue it's the federal reserve without
the federal reserve they never could
have pulled it off which is why they
wanted the federal reserve here is this
chart right that shows prices till today
so here we have this is sick that index
that is that 638 I mean look at that
thing going ballistic now you know if we
can come back in a couple of years and
put this chart up there wouldn't even be
enough room in this building we'd have
that we'd have to bore a hole through
the ceiling to going to show you where
that chart is going to go because the
Fed is on the verge now of destroying
the dollar here's another chart of
consumer prices 1913 at 2030 I mean
really this graphically I mean this is
without the Fed that's price stability
does that look like price stability to
you
I mean that's your definition of
stability I mean going up like that in
fact the Fed is now saying it's actually
admitting that its goal now is not price
stability right now its goal is
inflation of at least two percent a year
so that we don't accidentally fall into
deflation well you got to be you got
luck this is a really scary thought
this is what we got when the feds goal
was stable prices imagine what that line
looks like when it says its goal is
inflation right I mean it's gonna be
worse because if you really want stable
prices stable in my def in my mind
stable is like this right well that
would mean some year's prices go up and
then some years they go down and that's
how you get stability even if prices go
up 2% a year that's a lot of inflation
over time stable prices is not 2% up
every year stable is stable right so now
we didn't have say
prices we had escalating prices and now
they're going to escalate even more and
so where are we now because I got a few
minutes and you know what are these big
mistakes so where are we now the Fed has
got interest rates at zero it is
ignoring all of the damage being done
structurally to the US economy just like
ignore the housing bubble the trade
deficit is once again skyrocket current
account deficit government deficits are
exploding and the Fed is sitting there
with his foot on the gas
monetizing all his debt because the Fed
is afraid to allow the economy to
restructure because of the short-term
pain that that would involve but when we
abun not in 2008 what if we had not
bailed everybody out right and let the
chips fall let some banks fail let the
markets restructure wouldn't that be
better than piling on trillions and
trillions of dollars of additional debt
to grow the financial sector to grow the
government sectors the sectors that are
already bloated and too big
meanwhile the sectors that we need to
attract resources manufacturing you know
mining wealth production you know
continue to atrophy would have been
better to take the medicine would have
been even better to swallow that
medicine in 2001 had George Bush you
know not let us down this path had he
had he told the American public hey we
had this huge stock market bubble during
the 1990s we made a lot of mistakes we
did a lot of foolish things now we're
going to have to have a couple of tough
years as we unwind those mistakes that
we got under the Clinton presidency
under a green spent yes but no we didn't
do that but the problem is we've run out
of time here this is a gigantic bubble
that is bursting you can see all over
Europe countries are now having to deal
with their sovereign debt problems
Greece is the one that's that we're all
talking about but what is the difference
between America and Greece because a few
years ago Greece was just as broke as it
is now but there wasn't a crisis and the
reason there wasn't a crisis is because
the Greeks could still borrow money even
though they were broke even though they
couldn't pay it back interest rates were
still low at some point Greece's
creditors got nervous and they didn't
want to keep
and that's when it hit the fan well the
same thing is here we're just as broke
we can't pay our bills either right
that's why the Fed has to keep interest
rates really low because if the Fed lets
interest rates go up then just like
Greece we have to default we have to
restructure the US government cannot
afford to keep its commitments if rates
go up so the Fed keeps them down to prop
up the government to prop up the banks
but meanwhile that makes the problem
bigger it makes the debt bigger and it
means the burden is that much higher
when he eventually has to raise right
let rates rise and the longer he waits
the higher the rates are going to have
to go and and the bigger the damage now
some people will argue well we're
different than Greece because Greece
can't print money and we can yeah that's
why it's worse here because that's what
we might do if we print money instead of
defaulting if the Fed prints money
indefinitely because it doesn't want to
let interest rates go up because of the
pain that that's going to bring in then
we're going to have a currency crisis
we're going to have potentially
hyperinflation and the dollar will
collapse and Ben Bernanke will have
created something far worse than
anything that we endured during during
the Great Depression and you November
when when we embarked on this crazy
Keynesian experiment you know the
government was tiny on Hoover's last
budget was like four billion dollars and
I think Roosevelt doubled the size of
government to eat billion it was still
relatively small and you know a lot of
people say that well what really got us
out of the Second World War wasn't um
wasn't the who wasn't the New Deal
it was the civil it was a second world
war that fighting the war all that
wartime spending is what got us out it's
actually the exact opposite we got out
of the depression in 1946 when all the
wartime spending stopped yes a lot of
people got jobs during the war but they
were jobs in the army they were jobs in
factories making bombs I mean these
weren't jobs that were producing goods
and services that Americans got to enjoy
I mean time was tough in America during
the war everything was rationed you
could say that the worst part of the
Depression was during the war it was
after the war but we didn't have to
waste all that money
on war on soldiers building bombs when
we had all those resources returned to
the private sector when the government
slash spending that's when the recovery
really began
now unfortunately that's not what we're
looking at now we've got a Federal
Reserve that's made policy mistake after
policy mistake after policy mistake and
it refuses to accept any responsibility
for the damage it's done yet it
continues to do it I think the Federal
Reserve in contrast to what Ben Bernanke
said is probably the single most
dangerous institution in America and Ben
Bernanke should be regarded as public
enemy number one and you know I've seen
him I testified before Congress and
he'll even acknowledge when he's pressed
that the most serious problem that we
face as a nation is these big deficits
and he keeps saying but this is not the
feds fault and it's not up to the Fed he
says that this is all political BS it's
not political it is the feds fault
how does Ben Bernanke think the
government is getting away with all
these deficits it's the Fed buying up
all the bonds it's the Fed keeping
interest rates artificially low if the
Fed wasn't buying any bonds and it
wasn't buying any mortgages and it led
interest rates go up the government
would have no choice spending would have
to be slashed we would have to allow the
economy to restructure the only reason
that the politicians are not making the
tough choices is because Ben Bernanke
gives them an easy way out but what are
the ultimate consequences that we are
going to be faced with right when the
music stops when the dollar crashes when
the bond market crashes all of this is
going to happen you know I just did a
debate earlier today on CNN
International on this austerity versus
stimulus and people are saying you know
look at look at how Europe is suffering
with their austerity and we're doing
much better under stimulus first of all
they might have austerity there but it
may be some a lot of it is the wrong
kind and some of it is not all Stier
enough so I don't want to hold Europe up
as the poster boy of what to do right
but they're making fewer mistakes than
us but this is the point in this
short-run stimulus always feels better
right if you go if you're if you're a
drug addict and you
check in a rehab and as soon as you get
there they give you drugs well yeah I
mean that's great you're gonna have a
lot more fun than the rehab center that
sticks you in a room and makes you go
cold turkey but a rehab sorry hab Center
that's passing out drugs is not going to
you know rehabilitation curing drug
addiction right so that's what we've got
right and even I even got a Paul Volcker
that same cop to admit that he thinks
well yes Paul Volcker said the problem
in the US economy is that we have too
much borrowing and too much consumption
he admits that but then he supports the
stimulus because according to Paul Paul
Volcker well we need a little a little
more of the hair of the dog that bit us
as if more cheap money and more spending
is going to solve the problem look it's
like if you're overweight and if you're
300 pounds and and the doctor says like
you got you weigh too much you're going
to have a heart attack you need to go on
a diet this solution isn't to first put
on another hundred pounds because you
don't want to just go cold turkey got
all this and and then start losing
weight you know after you're 100 if
you're gonna if you're too fat at 300
it's even worse at 400 and it's going to
be even harder to drop the pounds you
got to drop them right now yeah maybe it
changes your lifestyle maybe you don't
like exercising maybe you don't like
eating salads and all that kind of
healthy stuff you want to eat junk food
you want to lie on the couch but that
doesn't get you healthy and right now
everything we're doing as an economy
thanks to the Federal Reserve stimulate
Ben Bernanke right one of his brilliant
statements he's said in these lectures
the problem is we don't have enough
demand we got too much demand right I
mean you know you know the old
expression shop till you drop we did it
you know we don't need any more demand
Ben Bernanke said the problem is
households are not spending and
borrowing as much as they did before the
crisis of course they're not they're
broke and the reason we had a crisis was
because households were borrowing and
spending too much and why were they
doing that because the Federal Reserve
made it so cheap that's why so we don't
want to return to the conditions that
created the problem we want to solve
those conditions the only way the
economy is going to be soft is going to
is going to restructure and have
lasting prosperity is if we do the exact
opposite of what we did to create the
problem that means we need less spending
we need less borrowing we need higher
interest rates the sooner the better
we need interest rates to go up so
savings go up consumption has to go down
we have to invest more we have to
produce more we have to export more we
have to shrink our trade deficit we have
to shrink our government we have to
repeal all these rules and regulations
that are making us uncompetitive instead
we are doing the exact opposite of
everything we need to do in fact if you
wanted to create a blueprint to destroy
America all you have to do is follow the
current plan and the Federal Reserve is
right at the forefront anyway now I know
I'm at I'm at the exact 1 hour mark so I
want to end my discussion and then open
it up to questions from audience
particularly from people who happen to
have heard a Ben Bernanke's lecture and
who might want to question me about the
you know the differences in what we're
saying yeah microphone first
[Applause]
my own here do I have the extra area on
thanks for cramming 2 hours worth of
information in the last 45 minutes I
when you ask a question please quickly
state your name and then ask a question
don't give a speech since I have the
microphone I'll ask the first question
which is there's been a tremendous
advance and kind of literacy about the
role of the Federal Reserve and central
banking and yet central banking remains
pretty persistently popular throughout
the world are there any examples of
people stepping back away from that kind
of centralizing ledge or where do you
see the this proceeding next on a
pragmatic point of view well I mean you
see examples in the market I mean look
at the price of gold when when central
bankers were really held in high regard
when people really trusted them people
didn't buy gold I mean gold was
languishing in the high 200s in 2000
people were very convinced that that
gold was an ancient relic that we didn't
need it anymore that we can trust the
central bankers to keep a lid on on
money creation to keep a lid on excess
government so that was really the heyday
you know the maestro Alan Greenspan
people really you know worship them and
then they had a lot of faith in in
paper-money and central banks with gold
at 1700 it's on it's been rising for 11
or 12 years in a row uh that confidence
is is is evaporating and rightly so and
so you can see that and all the central
banks if you look at the UK look at the
ECB look at the Bank of China look at
the Bank of Japan everybody's got
interest rates at zero or practically
zero even Switzerland has got them down
there uh and so there's no return on
currencies everybody is printing money
all these government's are hopelessly in
debt they have two choices default or
inflate those are their only two choices
because paying their bills isn't even an
option because they can't afford it so
if they're going to either way you don't
want to own their bonds because if they
default you don't get your money back if
they inflate you get your money back but
you don't get your purchasing power back
so people are buying gold we haven't yet
seen it
a national scale where a country has you
know gone back on a gold standard I
think that's going to happen I think
central banks have gone from selling
gold to buying gold I mean think about
how stupid these central bankers are
what were the central bankers doing in
the late 1990s when gold was 250 to 300
hours an ounce they were all selling
what a stupid thing for them to have
done to sell their goal that those low
prices so now they're buying it back but
still if you look at how much gold
central banks owned as a percentage of
the gold that's out there it's at
historically low levels and if you look
at the reserves the percentage of gold
as a reserve role in two currencies it's
90 some of the biggest countries like
China that have three trillion reserves
I forget what it is maybe 3% of those
reserves are gold you know 97 percent of
it is fiat paper and all these BRIC
nations ever they're all way under owned
so they're but they're moving now and
they're moving in that direction to
buying gold you can even see here in the
United States various states are
introducing legislation preparing for an
alternative to the dollar trying to have
gold circulate as legal tender within
their states so you can see this and
look at the price of oil I mean gasoline
prices now four dollars a barrel these
are record highs seasonally they're
going to hit record highs this summer $5
$6 and in a couple years it might be 10
$20 it might be $100 who knows if they
keep printing money prices are going to
go up prices for everything are going to
go up food clothing eventually even
consumer electronics are not going to be
able to to stop that tide so even if in
real terms prices are going down because
of efficiencies and economies of scale
even those prices are going to start to
rise because that's how much inflation
is in the pipeline and is being created
so as that happens you know people are
going to lose confidence I think the
dollar will lose its status as a reserve
currency and that's you know really when
it hits the fan questions
I don't manage Christian I'm an intern
Freedom Works and I was wondering what
you make of the argument that has been
put forth by people like Krugman as well
as Bernanke and Greenspan that the
housing bubble was a result of a savings
glut that emerged from China and other
East Asian Asian economies and was
exported to America which push down bond
rates and yeah effectively yeah I talked
about putting the cart before the horse
I was addressing this problem you know
back you know back in in 2002 2003 2004
it wasn't the the global savings glut it
was our trade deficits what happened was
we were spending all this cheap money
the Fed was creating all this money and
putting it into the economy the real
estate bubble was creating all this
purchasing power that people were
tapping into through home equity loans
and what were they doing with the money
that they extracted they were buying
stuff and where was the stuff made in
China and Japan and other countries and
so we were exporting all of this
currency but since we weren't
manufacturing things to sell to the
nations that we were buying from they
had all this extra dollars and so what
did they do with all these extra dollars
they loaned them back to us in the form
of buying Treasuries but ultimately the
Treasury yields were so low that
foreigners were not getting that good a
return on these Treasuries and that
created the demand for higher-yielding
mortgage-backed securities but the
problem was we had these enormous trade
deficits that because the dollar was the
reserve currency were being recycled
into dollar denominated assets mortgage
bonds Treasury bonds had the dollar
instead been allowed to fall which it
should have and these big surplus is not
accumulated we wouldn't have had this
but to blame our trade deficits on the
rest of the world surpluses is again
it's you know it's getting it in Reverse
right and so they're looking at it but I
talked about this at the problem and I
said this was what was fueling the
bubble because what would happen is we
would run these big trade deficits as a
result of all the stimulus and then our
trading partners would recirc 'el recite
recycle the money they earned back into
our mortgage mark
which would bring interest rates down
even more which would create another
wave of reef eyes and home equity
extractions which we would then take to
Walmart and buy more stuff to send more
dollars abroad that would come right
back and I said at the time and you can
read it I described it in crash-proof
I described this virtuous circle of how
it worked but that it was going to go in
Reverse once at first and in fact it's
amazing that Europe never really blamed
us for this financial crisis because how
did Europe get all this bad paper we
sold it to him we packaged it up and we
sold our you know our junk bonds
mortgages all around the world because
we were borrowing money there was a glut
of dollars from our trade surpluses but
if the Fed didn't have interest rates
down so low we wouldn't have been
consuming more than we produce we would
have had to save more right we would
have had to have produced more we
wouldn't have all these imbalances so
you can say yes foreigners are partially
to blame for not letting the dollar tank
right they should have let the dollar
collapse they should have said you know
the dollar can't be the reserve currency
anymore because it's not backed by gold
you have all these trade deficits and
they should have let the dollar sink
instead foreign central bank's try to
prop up the dollar and so to do that
they are buying up all these dollars and
then we were recirculating them back
into these these pots but again you
can't blame it you can say yes they're
partially to blame for not letting the
dollar tank but of course if they let
the dollar tank then we would have a
real crisis in America right now which
we're going to have eventually and as
far as I'm concerned the sooner the
better
I think that foreigners are not helping
us by delaying the pain it's like you
know a drug pusher giving you giving you
you know free drugs yeah I mean you
think he's doing you a favor until you
know all of a sudden you don't get the
free drugs anymore and that's what's
happening now we're living above our
means because of this but it's going to
come to an abrupt end and it's going to
be a very very painful process to try to
restructure this economy after years and
years and years of being able to consume
based on printing money because that's
going to stop
well we have one question from the
Facebook page before we move back
upfront and that is how do you see the
Federal Reserve being phased out of our
economy well I don't know if it's going
to be phased out of me to say but I
think we should do at least is return
the Federal Reserve to its original
mission right don't let it buy
government bonds
you know let's bring it back to its
initial limited function you know where
the Federal Reserve notes are backed
100% by commercial paper and 40% by gold
and let's have real money again and
follow the Constitution but if we do
that maybe we can gradually phase out
the Fed but you know a lot of people
think how can we go back to a gold
standard and of course I don't think of
it as going backwards to a gold standard
I think it's going forwards to a gold
standard because we went backwards to
paper the founding fathers were
forward-thinking they knew that paper
money didn't work and so they were
progressive they put us on a gold
standard we forgot about that and we
reverted to a failed system of fiat
money so we need to advance again to to
a gold standard but think about this we
were able to take the country from a
gold standard to a Fiat standard we went
from a dollar backed by something to a
dollar backed by nothing to me that
seems like a harder transition to make
than to go from a dollar back by nothing
the one that's backed by something right
does something that has real value
there's just not a piece of paper where
there's some limit on the ability to
just create it out of thin air so I
think it's I think it's a transition
that's very doable and that it will
ultimately happen you know right now I
advise people you know don't wait for
the official return of the gold standard
buy your goal now because when we're on
a gold standard it's gonna be a lot more
expensive
hello mr. Schiff yeah if my name is
Byron Sanford if we implemented tax
increases and spending cuts which
European countries are doing right now
what negative consequences do you see as
a result of that well I see no negative
consequences to spending cuts at all on
tax hikes it would depend on the type of
tax hikes that you're envisioning I mean
I do think that it is better for the
government to run on revenue than run on
debt right so increasing revenue through
taxation in general is better than
increasing revenue through borrowing or
printing so but I don't think the
problem in America is that the
government doesn't collect enough in
taxes I think the problem is that it
spends too much so I want to resolve
these imbalances with radical and
drastic reductions in government
spending that is the best way to attack
the problem but of course we need to let
interest rates rise too until we get
higher interest rates we're never going
to get at these real structural
imbalances because it's because of price
fixing
we need a market determined interest
rate not a interest rate that's
determined soviet-style you know by a
central planning division to just picks
an interest rate out of the sky but
what's also important when it comes to
taxation is that we need to reform the
way the government collects taxes that's
a key part even if we're going to
collect more revenues which I would
prefer not to do but if we're going to
balance the budget through a combination
of higher taxes and lower spending we
need to reform the taxes so that the new
taxes are coming off of consumption and
spending not off of savings and
investment in production so I don't want
to tax people for working and investing
I want to tax people for spending their
money and yes you know people say well
if you do that then the rich are going
to get off the hook no they're not going
to get off the hook the rich spend a lot
of money I mean they're rich they buy a
lot of expensive stuff so they can pay
taxes but if a rich person earns a lot
of money and doesn't spend it why
shouldn't we tax that money because he's
not enjoying it
he's not spending it what is a rich
person doing with the money he doesn't
spend it's being invested it's growing
the economy it's producing goods it's
creating jobs so any money that the
government takes from a wealthy person
that that wealthy person wouldn't have
spent directly diminishes economic
growth it directly diminishes employment
if you think that you create economic
growth and create jobs by taking money
away from entrepreneurs and business and
giving it to politicians right a
government and there is no historical
evidence that that works in fact all the
historical evidence is the opposite
right when governments are in control of
resources their squandered you don't get
economic growth
get you get widespread poverty so we
want to leave wealth in the private
sector so we can raise our living
standards and create jobs and it all
gets caught up in demagogues a well but
the rich aren't paying taxes okay fine
what are they doing with their money
right they're investing it tax them when
they spend it if you buy you know you
buy something you pay a tax and and and
so we need to move the tax code in that
direction if we just do what Obama wants
to do raise taxes on the rich is
probably going to backfire I mean I mean
I would fall into the category of rich
and right now what are my taxes I'm
paying 35% federal income tax plus 2.9
percent federal you know Medicare tax
that's 38 percent of my money plus theta
Connecticut seven percent factoring you
know so that puts me over forty percent
of my total income is because I've been
up 19 plus ninety five ninety nine
percent of my income is taxed at the
marginal rate so that's over forty
percent of my income right there and
that doesn't count what I pay in
property taxes sales taxes Social
Security taxes corporate taxes all kinds
of hidden taxes I'm already probably
about 50 percent how much more my am I
going to take are they going to take it
up to 55 percent 60 percent you know how
many people are even going to work under
that type of this confiscatory rates of
Taxation you know yeah and which means
the government might end up getting
nothing I mean it's better to get 20
percent of something than 70 percent of
nothing and more importantly it's not
only that what about the jobs that are
destroyed or never created because the
entrepreneurs don't have that capital to
grow their businesses they sent it all
the Washington so you know trying to tax
people who are already overtaxed is not
going to do it you know and meanwhile
half the people in the country aren't
even paying any income taxes yes they
pay Social Security taxes but you know
they think that raising income taxes
doesn't cost them any money well maybe
it cost them their job because they
can't get a job because the capital
needed to provide that job was sent to
Washington instead so we need you know
we created all that wealth I talked
about the 19th century and all the
wealth that was created Jordan income
taxes at all
nobody those wealthy men that created
all these fortunes and grew this economy
paid no federal income taxes they paid
no state income taxes nothing so we need
to move more towards that model of free
in capitalism you know not try to
continue this broken model do we have
the questions from the Bernanke class
crew here who wants to take their loan
okay thank you mr. Schiff yeah my name
is David Pomeroy I had a question for
you about the gold standard and I was
wondering some of the sharp the charts
that you showed seemed to be shown a
simplified version of the gold standards
record in the 1800's having it smoothed
out over the long term but don't show
the wild short-term fluctuations which
are in excess of 5% inflation and
deflation yeah well I don't know what
you can see from that from that slide
but there were periods of time under a
bowl standard where you saw that but it
always coincided with a period of time
where we kind of temporarily veered from
it such as a civil war where we
introduced for the first time greenbacks
into circulation and we did have an
inflation that that would that ran with
the civil war when the war ended and the
notes came out of circulation prices
resumed so what you're looking at is a
long term trend that was like this and
yes there were there were there were
bumps but you're looking at a hundred
year chart to show the overall direction
of prices which was down and you look at
the chart of the twentieth century
particularly the second half of the 20th
century worio now you're looking at a
movement like this so while that is true
there were some pretty variable
fluctuations in 1800s and while it was a
long-term stable it wasn't short-term
stable whereas now it is not long-term
stable but it is more short-term I don't
know how you can call it short-term
stable if you if you consider stability
going up every year I might the goal
short term stability and I'm talking
about is when it goes up 5% inflation
and then down 5 percent deflation 2
years later so that's pretty pretty
unstable compared to today's standards
how is far during as far as I should for
you is well is why are the short-term
fluctuations more desirable than the
long-term stability well I don't think
we have stability
I don't think creating perpetual
inflation and as I said if you look at
the economic experience of the 19th
century look at the increase in living
standards right during that period of
time compared to today it was much
stronger we produced more econom
growth we raised living standards for
more people higher even with whatever
those short-term fluctuations were they
were not nearly as problematic as what
we've got now we've eviscerated the
middle class that was was created with
with limited government and sound money
I mean now Americans are all in debt I
mean the average American has a negative
net worth now I mean he's he's broke I
mean his share of the national debt
Dwarfs whatever a minimal amount he has
in savings or in home equity you know I
mean so we the economy is struggling
under the weight of all this government
and central banking and we haven't even
experienced the complete end result the
real crisis the real day of reckoning
from this experiment with fiat money
that's not in our past yet that's in our
future I mean it's going to get a whole
lot worse and then a lot of people are
going to see exactly the damage that has
been done by by central bankers and
government thank you very much for
speaking we hope we all attended it um
my question is returning to the gold
standard as you mentioned no country
right now is on the gold standard but
you said that you think that in the
future countries will go back to the
gold standard yeah I mean when we left
the gold standard in 1971 Richard Nixon
said it was temporary that's what he
said I mean it wasn't his intention so
so just to finish the thought so looking
back many many countries had been on the
gold standard in the past and every
single one of them has ended in the
country going off the gold standard in
the UK and in Germany and during the
Great Depression was because they just
ran out of gold
well it didn't have enough gold to cover
it so what makes you think that if a
country were to return to the gold
standard in the future they would be
able to maintain it and just wouldn't
end in them going off the gold snag as
in every other circumstance in history
yeah well the reason it's not that they
run out of gold see they don't want to
allow deflation they don't want to allow
prices to adjust to the quantity of gold
so yeah so politics that you don't run
out so politicians don't like the gold
standard for the very reasons that
Bernanke laid out it prevents them from
selling snake oil to their constituents
in exchange for their votes the
politicians want to pretend that they
can spend money to solve problems the
gold standard
is in their way so it's the politicians
that want to remove the gold standard
ultimately its people that are going to
want it back people want real money
people want sound money now the last
country that went off the gold standard
was Switzerland I mean these day hold
out the longest but one by one all the
politicians followed our example we led
the world off the gold standard we're
probably going to lead them back not
necessarily because we adopt the gold
standard first but because we destroy
the dollar in their reserves and they
have to replace it with something and so
once we've destroyed the dollar the
question is what does the world do to
replace it are they just going to take
the euro are they going to take the yen
the China the RMB or they can go back to
the dollar remember the reason we were
able to sell the world on the dollar as
the reserve as opposed to gold because
everybody was using gold and we said hey
use the dollar instead of gold and
basically what we said is we own all the
gold we've got 90 plus percent of the
world's gold anyway
where'd we get all that gold we sold
products and they paid in gold because
they didn't have the products we they
didn't manufacture like we did because
they had bigger government's than we did
so we had all the gold we were the
world's biggest creditor nation we we
had investments all around the world we
had massive inflows from our foreign
investments we were by far the
wealthiest creditor nation and we said
look hold dollars the dollar is as good
as gold
you don't need gold you've got the
dollar you can have your gold whenever
you want it just bring $35 to the
Treasury and will hand you an ounce of
gold in the meantime you can get paid
interest on your dollars you don't get
paid any interest on your gold so we
convince the world based on the strength
of our balance sheet based on a dollar
being as good as gold
to take the dollar as the reserve so
when when when when this whole thing
collapses the most likely thing is that
we go back to the way it was before the
dollar became the reserve currency not
that we simply replace some lesser
flawed fiat currency for the dollar
yeah just when you said that the United
States and all these foreign investments
that had gold coming into the country
inflows of gold during that during that
period but we had income from our
foreign investor IRA of course so if you
kind of follow that to his conclusion
which happened during the Great
Depression if the dollar if the United
States is so strong if any country is so
strong that there's continuous inflows
of gold into the United States
eventually the United States will have
all the gold nobody else will have any
gold the Wow well and then end up off
the gold standard
no no because no because what's gonna
then we're gonna have to start using our
goal to buy some of their stuff and the
gold will flow back out but you know it
because both look if the world ran out
of gold
through threat eclis right well then we
would just produce stuff for ourselves
instead if we're gonna export something
the world has to pay for it right you
know so it isn't a problem the problem
is the Fiat standard I mean gold
standards have worked historically for
hundreds of years I mean the founding
fathers knew this these were smart guys
they put us on a gold standard for a
reason they studied history and unlike
Ben Bernanke they not only understood it
but learned from it and so they put us
on a gold standard and and it served us
very well we were a tiny country you
know we were an afterthought to Europe
in 1789 we were a few million people you
know here in the new world yet we
created a society in just a hundred year
time period that we created a standard
of living well beyond anything in Europe
how did we do that we did that on a gold
standard we did that with no government
with a tiny government and freedom we
were freer than all the Europe and so we
prospered more than Europe you know
we came in with this with this with with
a Fiat standard you know we started in
1913 but we didn't really go off it
until 1971 look at the disastrous result
look at the collapse of the value of our
money look at skyrocketing prices I mean
look at before the Federal Reserve came
into existence in America if you were a
man in this country and you'd even have
a high school degree you could get a job
your wife could stay at home you do not
she'd have to get a job you can support
her you can have four kids right you can
save for your retirement you can buy
things you had a great standard of
living
now if you
you know there's no way I mean you got
the average man even with a with a
master's degree his wife has a job and
they have to delay even having one kid
until they're in their late thirties
because they can't afford to have them
because they're drowning in debt
and you know and even when they have
kids what it's one or two kids and
they're struggling and they have no
savings and they're deep in debt so we
have destroyed the middle class that
freedom and the gold standard built and
the Federal Reserve is a big reason for
that just yeah my name's Troy Benson and
I agree that onyx and geometric waiting
these things have heavily skewed the CPI
over the years and have changed really
you know our view of inflation but given
the amount of excess reserves that are
now sitting on the balance sheets of
mini fat financial institutions where
basically this money isn't being lent
out it's just being pent up in these
financial institutions it's now exceeded
trillions of dollars I mean do you think
that eventually the Fed will try to
intervene and try to force the banks to
lend that money out well it is being it
is being loaned out I mean the banks are
buying bonds they're buying Treasuries
they're buying mortgage-backed
securities so the money is being loaned
out the problem is it's not being loaned
out in a productive manner it's not
being loaned out to entrepreneurs to
make capital investments to grow the
economy it's financing trillion dollar
budget deficits it's financing inflated
housing prices that is the problem and
yes you know this the way we measure
inflation is all government you know
propaganda and again just like Ben
Bernanke denied there was a housing
bubble even though it should have been
plain as day now he denies there's
inflation but when when the Boscombe
Commission was convened back you know in
the 1990s they had a stated goal
according to that commission the CPI
overstated inflation meaning that they
thought the numbers were too high so
they were going to fix the problem and
they deliberately tried to find a way to
get a lower number see it's not a
conspiracy that's what they did and so
they did all kinds of things so the
number would be lower and now it is
lower but it's not because inflation is
lower it's because we're measuring it
differently and of course you know the
Federal Reserve all they like to look at
is you know the personal consumption
expenditure index which is the most
irrelevant of all because really what
that measures is survival not the cost
of living it's the
cost of surviving because there you know
if the price of steak goes up so much
that you can't afford steak anymore so
you buy hamburger instead but hamburgers
also gotten a lot more expensive but
it's all you can afford even if the
hamburger is more expensive than the
state you used to buy the government's
gazelle that's a price cut because look
you're saving all this money cuz you're
buying hamburger right then of course
you know you can you can take the same
art well what if the price of hamburger
gets really expensive so I have to buy
dog food right Arlo's there's no
inflation because I'm still eating you
know this you shake it your head so
maybe you think I got something wrong
yeah but that's that's how they do it
for the personal consumption expenditure
they do substitution oh yeah because you
know the example you gave about
substituting steak for for Hamburg
actually they're in different different
categories
yeah like categories different universal
steak and hamburger wouldn't be the same
when there's a substitution it wouldn't
be but they do substitute but if the
price is something goes up they'll kick
it out and they'll substitute something
where the price thing goes up I mean the
way the way we do is we have actually
people who go into stores hmm and they
actually go and look at that if the item
is not there they look for another item
that goes into that category and if it
fits that category then we substitute
yeah what about what about with hedonic
because I often hear where the
government is going to say when the
price went up they're going to say well
the quality went up and so they're
claiming that the price went down but in
my experience most of the things I'm
buying I'm seeing the quality going down
where they're substituting cheaper
ingredients they're using lower quality
inputs they're shrinking the size things
like that and then they're doing that
instead of raising the price is the
government going in and saying gee you
know you used to go to a restaurant and
the restaurant used to charge you know
ten dollars for the salad and now they
still charge ten dollars but it's half
the size right are they going and saying
that's adult price double what's
happening now is that we notice that
producers and you know people who
actually produce the products they're
actually down side down sizing as you
said they're downsizing on their
products but we do raiser those changes
in downsizing
when we when we enter the prices it
doesn't it does it certainly doesn't
appear that may from the numbers I work
in the collection part of the CNI so I
really don't know what's gone on at the
end of the because I talk to I talked to
people who small business owners and
business owners are usually you know
they watch their prices their input
costs very closely because they're
trying to make a profit so they have to
know what their consular and everybody
that calls my radio show no matter what
their business is they've got the same
gripe my costs keep going up prices are
going up and these are big increases and
they're all businesses that are totally
unrelated plus true I mean costs are
going up but that whoa so why isn't that
reflected well you have to understand
that I mean a lot of people have this
misconception and that exactly you know
the most knowledge of person to CDI
because you know I'm only 25 years old
so I started working about two years ago
there but the CPI measures the average
change of a basket of course so it
doesn't measure one specifically so but
the basket is changing the basket isn't
even static but the thing is the lost
costs are prices they're the same thing
yeah it just depends on your perspective
but one person's cost is somebody else's
price well they're not that they'll ask
it that the CPI measures the hours of
all the items included not only one I
think that's why that's why that's why
an employer might so that's the core
when they take when they then they take
energy and food out but you know the
bottom line is see the problem is
inflation is not rising prices inflation
is an expansion of the money supply the
government isn't even measuring prices
they're measuring inflation rather
they're measuring the effect of
inflation but the fact that the Fed
isn't creating inflation shouldn't even
be debated quantitative easing is just
the feds name for inflation they just
don't want to call inflation inflation
because then we'll know what it is so
they call it quantitative easing because
it sounds better than inflation but
that's what it is
I'm not censoring the Bureau of Labor
says it a hard deadline I want to thank
especially Peter Schiff Andrew ship as
well Freedom Works Matt kibbe students
for liberty and all of you for coming
out here and having a robust discussion
on the Federal Reserve and freedom damn
it freedom
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]